autres invités politiques ce matin c'est
joël giraud bonjour bonjour si beaucoup
d'être avec nous secrétaire d'état à la
ruralité on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale
bonjour sébastien qu'on attend bonjour
merci d'être avec nous sébastien cours
atteint 2 les coûts républicain on
commence bien sûr par ce débat qui a
lieu cette semaine au parlement et hier
l'assemblée nationale a largement adopté
le report des régionales et
départementales les 20 et le 27 juin
c'est ce que demandait le gouvernement
le scrutin il va donc tomber le premier
week-end des vacances d'été est ce que
vous prenez pas le risque de renforcer
l'abstention avec ces dates écouter de
toute façon en fait je crois que une
campagne comme la campagne des
régionales ce qui est important et quand
vous avez un des ventes assez d'avoir un
peu de pédagogie avant c'est-à-dire de
faire en sorte que les citoyens puissent
comprendre à quoi sert cette élection à
quoi servent les départements à quoi
servent les régions dans un pays qui n'a
jamais vraiment fait de la pédagogie
j'allais dire des scrutins électoraux
après quand on a envie de voter avec un
système qui est 30 ans nous soit dit
permet aujourd'hui de partir quand même
en vacances et d'avoir une procuration
bon je pense que ce n'est pas ça qui va
provoquer quelque chose de très grave au
niveau 2 de l'ascension ce qui ce qui
est plus grave c'est l'abstention
généralisée des gens qui se détache de
la politique et qui n'ont pas envie
d'aller aux urnes je crois que
malheureusement c'est plutôt là dessus
qu'il faut agir et c'est ce que je tente
modestement de faire dans la ruralité en
expliquant aux gens que c'est bien de
faire comme avant c'est à dire les
ruraux vous savez allez allez beaucoup
aux urnes
quand on avait je vous rappelle même que
j'ai été classé aux régionales et
j'étais vice président d'une région
on faisait des scores incroyablement
élevé
en termes de participation dans les deux
départements à le faire ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait le cas des départements
littoraux
à telle enseigne d'ailleurs que ça
pouvait faire basculer le scrutin de
manière très spectaculaire alors que
nous étions que quelques centaines de
milliers d'habitants eh bien je crois
que c'est plutôt là dessus qu'il faut
agir mais dates des vacances en soit je
ne pense pas que ce soit la chose la
plus la plus pertinente a opposé mais
quand même pourquoi l'avoir décalée
d'une semaine sachant que le sénat s'y
était opposé au moment du vote de la loi
sur le report des élections
oui mais coûteux tout ce que là aussi
vous prenez pas le risque
mais tout ce qui permet si vous voulez
de faire en sorte qu'on soit le plus
loin possible dans la vaccination des
personnes et tout ce qui permet de
garder le cap du mois de juin c'est à
dire de ne pas avoir encore à réviser un
texte moi me semble plutôt bon voilà
c'est raisonnable et les maires se sont
exprimés je vois là ce prix met en prise
directe sans passer par les associations
comme l'association des maires de france
quel sens avait cette consultation est
ce que ce n'était pas ainsi un signal de
défiance
écoutez je vais beaucoup de remontées de
maires ruraux qui se posaient la
question de la pertinence de ce de ce
scrutin effectivement au mois de juin
par rapport au mois de septembre et
j'étais bien incapable de leur donner
une véritable réponse je le dis
clairement le fait d'avoir demandé aux
maires en direct si oui ou non il était
favorable au maintien des élections en
juin a permis de dégager bas tout
simplement une majorité qui était pas si
violent que ça parce que 56 44
c'est quand même pas la majorité la plus
large sur jure de ses passes sur
consensuelle ça veut dire tout
simplement qu'ils avaient même partagé
que les choses n'étaient pas si pire que
ça
mais l'association des maires de france
est vous avez fait connaître sa position
pourquoi refaire une consultation des
maires ben moi j'écoutais l'association
des maires ruraux de france qui n'était
pas tout à fait sur la même position que
du mois se poser beaucoup de questions
non n'emportait pas d'ailleurs de
réponses forcément mais se poser
beaucoup de questions
je pense que faire globalement bas
je savais reprocher à des indigents et
notamment à un gouvernement de prendre
le fou de la démocratie des élus pour
savoir si vraiment les maires sont
opposés la tenue de ces élections par
c'est pourquoi le faire comme ça
pourquoi le faire un vendredi soir avec
des réponses à apporter le lundi matin
sachant que les mairies sont souvent
fermés le vendredi après midi que
certains oui mais 62 et 70 pour les
mairies afin dé mûri dans aux gens de
droite sont ouvertes le samedi
la plupart des scrutins mais mais c'est
une sensation un peu précipité quand
même c'était pour savoir avant le débat
effectivement il faut prendre le pouls
des mers et pour pas être c'était pour
ne pas être jédir est en contradiction
est ce que pensaient les maires et
aujourd'hui les maires se sont exprimés
ça me semble de la démocratie directe
on l'aurait pas fait on nous aurait dit
vous auriez mieux fait de les consulter
bon donc je là dessus moi je suis d'une
d'une grande sérénité puis 70 % de
réponses ça veut dire quand même que
même si c'était un week-end même si
c'est rapide
le scrutin s'il y avait des élections il
n'y a pas tant de % d'abstention on en
prendrait bien souvent ailleurs
oui justement parmi les maires certains
pointent des difficultés notamment en
milieu rural
quelle application des normes sanitaires
comment trouver des volontaires pour
tenir les bureaux de vote quelles
garanties quels outils vont être
proposées à ses élus pour que le scrutin
se passe convenablement
déjà je pense que y ait une première
garantie qui est sûre la progression
effectivement de la vaccination qui va
faire que aujourd'hui on a une
circulation virale qui est importante et
qui au jour puisque aujourd'hui on en
est je crois
11 millions 300 mille personnes qui ont
été vaccinées du moins s'agissant de la
première injection
on va arriver sur quelque chose au
moment des élections je peux pas vous
donner un chiffre possible parce
qu'évidemment ça dépendra de la mise sur
marché d'un certain nombre de vaccins
mais on va arriver sur une vaccination
qui va quand même concerné près de près
de la moitié de la population
c'est-à-dire sans doute et à mon avis
plus de 70% des électeurs même 75% des
électeurs donc ça va être en mettre dans
une situation qui sera sanitairement
meilleur il faudra peut-être faire ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'on a fait justement
dans les voies juste que vous receviez
c'est de faire gagner c'est à dire que
on s'est mis en position d'avoir un
système de séparatif extrêmement
extrêmement dur pour pouvoir faire cette
consultation que je souhaitais faire
auprès des acteurs du massif avec
jean-baptiste lemoyne
non pas parce que j'étais dans une
précipitation absolue de faire cela pour
pour embêter les vosgiens et c'est tout
simplement parce qu'il ya une réunion
interministérielle la première qui a
lieu les lundis et qu'il fallait bien
que je consulte les principaux massifs
avant avant lundi voilà juste donc avec
des moyens sur les qui sont des moyens
complémentaires je pense qu'on va
arriver à quelque chose qui sur le plan
sanitaire et est plus qu'acceptable
voilà est-ce que vous êtes inquiets
notamment dans les communes rurales de
la difficulté à trouver des assesseurs
pour ce scrutin
non je ne pense pas je ne pense pas très
honnêtement parce que je connais quand
même bien les zones rurales jeu c'est la
mobilisation des gens je n'ai jamais vu
dans les zones rurales de démobilisation
vis-à-vis même de situations extrêmement
difficiles
ça va j'ai été merveilleux sept ans et
il y avait des grosses chutes de neige
les gens voyaient les des voitures un
peu dans tous les sens parce que c'était
le vendredi qui est des taux et ce
qu'ils venaient spontanément les gens
débouler en mairie ou dans les services
de gendarmerie en disant s'il ya des si
et des gens notamment avec des enfants
on a tous chambres de trois chambres
mais là c'est pareil je veux dire les
gens dans le rural se mobilisent quelles
que soient les circonstances et se
mobiliseront parce qu'ils savent le prix
de la démocratie dernier mot sur ces
élections avant deux pas de la crise
sanitaire avec sébastien vous serez
candidat voit ces élections régionales
ou départementales savait écouter
départementale l'accrétion la réponse
est non aux régionales je suis dans le
comité de soutien de sophie cluzel dans
la région provence alpes côte d'azur et
ça veut dire que vous serez sur salies
je pourrais être en queue de liste sur
la liste c'est à dire position
d'éligible 6 si c'était nécessaire
je le dis clairement parce que je crois
je veux dire à la candidature de ce fils
était nécessaire ça veut dire si elle
est nécessaire c'est essentiel
l'estiment nécessaire moi je te sens je
serai présent vous savez elle a commencé
sa campagne chez moi je lui ai proposé
de rencontrer justement le monde
agricole pour qu'elle connaisse bien les
spécificités du monde agricole dans les
zones de montagne
ça va on a une région qui est très
particulière entre marseille et briançon
il y à une certaine distance et il ya
une certaine différence de culture aussi
donc je ferai tout ce que je peux pour
qu'elle soit élue est calé score le plus
exclus lors qu'ils qui soit mais je ne
serai pas en position si vous voulez
éligibles parce que ça me demanderait
tout simplement de ne pas me préoccuper
de ce pour quoi j'ai été désigné membre
du gouvernement c'est à dire la mise en
place de l'agenda rural et d'ailleurs je
les dis à l'association des maires
ruraux de france je le redis rassurez
vous je ne serai pas
un ministre en campagne alors qu'il ya
des urgences dans la ruralité dernier
mot là dessus puisque vous parlez de
sophie cluzel christophe castaner il
tend la main à renaud muselier qu'est le
président de la région sud est de
l'autre côté sophie cluzel a dit mais
moi je serai candidate
y'a pas un problème mais c'est à dire
que christophe à lui a proposé de tendre
la main elle l'a fait et on a vu chez
lié n'a pas saisi la main tendue donc
elle n'en a tiré des conséquences c'est
ça sera là ce serait effectivement la
seule solution et j'espère très
sincèrement j'espère que oui j'espère
sincèrement qu'au deuxième tour les le
camp républicain se rassemblera et on va
parler de la crise sanitaire
oui à la vaccination des plus de 55 ans
a débuté cette semaine avec un mois
d'avancé sur le calendrier initial or le
sont les syndicats des pharmaciens il y
aurait plus de candidats au vaccin que
doses disponibles est ce que le
gouvernement ait pas aller trop vite sur
7 sur ce dossier écoutez moi je pense
qu'il y avait une forte demande de gens
qui avions qui souhaitaient être
vaccinés pour des raisons diverses et
variées soit parce qu'ils avaient dans
leur proximité dans leur entourage des
gens qui étaient en situation de
faiblesse soif avril deux bonnes raisons
il ya des gens qui veulent être vaccinés
aujourd'hui petit à petit les serrer
l'étau j'irai des critères et autres va
nous permettre tout simplement de
vacciner un maximum de gens c'est un peu
tiré le corner de ce que l'on disait
tout à l'heure sur la tenue des
élections
je crois que plus on n'ouvre plus on
aura de gens vaccinés mois le virus
circulera gonflé à l'heure actuelle je
pense que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dans des milieux qui sont
des milieux où il rencontre beaucoup de
gens ou la distanciation social n'est
pas forcément facile ça n'est pas un
critère en soi parce que ça vous le
ressentez vous même de la même façon que
vous lever le matin
si vous êtes normalement constitué vous
apercevez que vous avez de la fièvre
vous avez rendez vous avec une
une personne qui est en vous savez
qu'elle a eu des pathologies graves
vous remettez le rendez vous parce que
vous leur mettez deux rendez-vous
d'ailleurs parce que même si la personne
en question shop votre gates au vote
engine
elle va être très gravement malade donc
voilà je crois que tout cela
tout cela permet d'ouvrir mieux la
vaccination beaucoup de gens qui sont
inquiets à juste titre d'ailleurs
puisque cette pandémie est très grave et
qui pourront ainsi être entre guillemets
rassurer et rassurer leurs proches un
jugement vous parlez des prises de
rendez-vous dans certains secteurs
ruraux les personnes à mobilité réduite
sont parfois très éloignés des centres
de vaccination n'a eu que des exemples
est ce qui est assez dispositif pour les
aider afin de brigades mobiles partout
n'auriez pas de rien ne lui est
justement on a fait une réunion et
brigitte bourguignon avec les
associations d'élus pour voir comment
mettre en place un vade-mecum j'allais
dire est qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
consenti par les élus parce que sans ça
ça n'a pas de sens on va pas se
substituer aux élus d'en dans un certain
nombre de domaines mais voir les
échanges de bonnes pratiques et hautain
vade mecum soit d'aimer comme ben je
j'ai reçus y relatera mais on va pouvoir
le signer et l'envoyer à l'ensemble des
élus pour qu'il y ait justement plus de
repérage des personnes isolées d'une
manière générale qu'il s'agisse le
handicap
est-ce qu'il s'agisse de deux zones très
éloignées et après vous savez il ya des
initiatives un peu partout qui sont
assez admirable
il ya des initiatives aussi personnel je
mens je connais beaucoup de hameaux ou
de tous nous ont fait comme pour emmener
les gosses à l'école
c'est à dire qu'en fait en sorte que le
papier ou la mamie qui n'avait pas eu le
vaccin parce que peut pas sortir de sa
maison elle se former sur les sites les
mets de venir dans la ruralité un peu
plus organisés on va dire il ya des bus
départementaux il y à des bus j'ai vu
des bus france services qui ont été
désarmés entre guillemets de leurs
fonctions offrant ce service parce
qu'ils avaient un frigo était clair pour
pouvoir se rendre dans la ruralité a
fait partout jurf et d'initiatives
locales sont importantes il faut
simplement que les gens sachent que ces
initiatives existent que si cette île
soit partagé parce qu'une bonne idée ce
partage et c'est le but de ce que nous
avons menées comme action avec la
logique pour jauzion sur le vaccin
puisqu'on a appris hier que le vaccin
johnson and johnson et l avoir une pause
aux états unis du coup on attend l'avis
de l'agencé européenne du médicament
c'est un vaccin qui est quand même
pratique c'est un vaccin qui est mono
dos et un vaccin qui peut être
administrée par les pharmaciens par les
infirmiers par les médecins libéraux est
ce que du coup ça avoir enfin avoir des
conséquences sur la vaccination en
milieu rural bah écoutez je ne sais pas
je ne saurais vous le dire de manière
très précise
après il ya toujours une méfiance vis à
vis avec 100 pratique justement il y
avait une pratique il ya toujours une
méfiance vis-à-vis de des vaccins dans
ce pays plus que dans d'autres
d'ailleurs ce jeu les remarques et on se
pose moins de questions en italie ou aux
moines question en allemagne mais bon
aujourd'hui vous n'arrivez pas à savoir
si ça va avoir un enfant
je n'en ai strictement aucune idée vous
savez en matière de vaccination
les choses sont relativement simples
vous avez des vaccins qui ont été
autorisés ou non avec des risques qui
sont différents des rapports qu'aux
avantages qui sont différents voilà il y
compris pour les gens qui croient que je
connais beaucoup de gens qui ont des
problèmes d'allergie gens dont je fais
partie d'ailleurs et ben voilà il faut
attendre un certain système d'auto de
tests pour vérifier que vous n'aurez pas
de problème avec un vaccin plutôt qu'un
autre et je vous choisissez ensuite
celui qui au bout d'un mois n'a pas
provoqué des effets secondaires sur un
test voilà c'est comme ça
un dernier mot sur un autre sujet ça
concerne tout particulièrement les mères
qui mettent en oeuvre la campagne de
vaccination ils ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts ces mères mais ça a un coût de
mettre en oeuvre cette campagne de
vaccination notamment dans les communes
rurales
est ce que l'état s'engage à compenser
l'intégralité du coût de cette campagne
de vaccination on énonce les camps alors
non seulement on est sur une sur vous
savez qu'il ya un groupe de travail qui
regardent l'intégralité des
problématiques
on va dire des dépenses et des recettes
des collectivités locales il y à des
dépenses qui sont encore plus
importantes je vais être très clair qui
sont d'un certain nombre de dépenses
liées à des tarifs par exemple vous
aviez l centre balnéoludique une famille
une méga piscine dans le personnel ait
été salarié de droit public et vous avez
dû les conserver
donc globalement ces questions voix vue
dans le cadre de ce groupe de travail de
façon à proposer des compensations alors
ces compensations va arriver en décalage
par rapport au vote des budgets mais on
ne peut pas non plus ces compensations
normalement devraient être incluses dans
le plf
je ne pense pas que le projet de loi
finances jeu suivant arrivé en fin
d'année ou et plus tôt et ça sera
compensée intégralement ça vous et ça
sera compensée au maximum de ce qui est
possible parce qu'il faut peser les
recettes et les dépenses sur ce genre de
choses je suis incapable de vous dire le
pourcentage exact mais globalement sur
ces dépenses là bien évidemment on sera
beaucoup plus attentifs que sur d'autres
dépenses qui sont par exemple des
piscines ou des cinémas municipaux voilà
on va parler de l'actualité on va parler
du gel oui le gel qui a frappé de
nombreux territoires notamment les
cultures dont votre territoire et les
hautes-alpes est ce que vous arrivez à
mesurer à l'impact de cette catastrophe
météo écoutez on est en train de faire
le recensement de ce qui s'est passé et
qui vivait très grave au moment où le
gel s'est produit moi j'étais en
déplacement dans le département de la
gironde et j'ai vu des ddd des cépages
entier qui sont passés à la trappe avec
des ceps de vigne qui sont complètement
rabougri avec les feuilles qui ont
grillé comme vous le savez quand il ya
un épisode de gel on ne voit pas
immédiatement les dégâts provoqués sur
les sur les différentes plantes chez moi
ce sont les arboriculteurs
il ya des zones qui sont équipés avec
des systèmes de chauffage ou ou de
d'arrosage gélif comme jean département
et des autres lignes sont pas équipés
donc ce qui est clair c'est que de toute
façon il y aura là pour le compte une
année système d'indemnisation 26ème des
calamités agricoles qui sera fixée au
maximum
la seule question qu'on doit se poser
maintenant mais elle est plus large
d'ailleurs c'est que tout cela est
consécutif au dérèglement du climat
parce que vous avez de plus en plus de
ça vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières semaines que vous voulez vous
en plus de cas les gens soient pas
malades et le chantier d'ailleurs il
fait quelque chose dit il comprit autres
groupes locaux vides
et 26 degrés un jour le lendemain vous
voyez la neige qui tombe donc ces
dérèglements du climat ont des
conséquences sur les agriculteurs sur
les productions ils ont des conséquences
sur les territoires aussi jamais on n'a
autant d'effondrement de deux ans de
montagnes jamais on n'a eu d'autant
d'effondrements de routes dans les zones
de montagne du justement donc je crois
qu'il va falloir que nous réfléchissions
au système dit global des catastrophes
et des calamités qu'elles soient
agricoles ou la soie naturelle au regard
du système assurantiel parce qu'on avait
trouvé un équilibre qui correspondait à
une situation climatique qui n'est pas
la situation climatique actuel donc je
pense qu'il va falloir regarder de plus
près ces questions assurantiel parce que
on ne peut pas être dans un système où
l'assurance monde de plus en plus les
prix pour couvrir des quelque chose qui
est un phénomène naturel est un
phénomène qui d'ailleurs ne relève plus
de l'exception au bout d'un moment ce
qui est le principe même d'une
catastrophe puisque car vous avez des
séries d'éboulement toujours au même
endroit au même on se pose la question
de l'arrêté de catastrophe naturelle
anzani mais ça fait six fois sur au même
endroit qu'est ce qui se passe
il va falloir voir des systèmes
assurantiels plus adapté je ne sais pas
sous quelle forme très honnêtement mais
qui soit plus adapté à la réalité du
réchauffement climatique sur tout
territoire une question d'un questions
d'actualité avant de parler de vos
dossiers avec sébastien serra concerne
la loi cadre d elle arrivera conseil des
ministres écoutez maintenant on est sur
un timing qui rapprochait avec un débat
le tonneau au sénat donc à l'automne au
sénat
loto national donc voilà sauf
catastrophe majeure
ça va bien sourit ça tout à fait ça
l'est ça va ça va bien se passer et a
dit en conseil des ministres et quand je
n'ai pas la date injures jacqueline la
jacqueline gourault là je n'ai pas la
date exacte on attend les retours du
conseil d'état bien évidemment
la rentrée à la rendre savez on a envoyé
des éléments complémentaires au conseil
d'état sur un certain nombre de sujets
j'en suis ouvert d'ailleurs lors d'un
débat au sénat les sénateurs eux mêmes
des initiatives je suis ce soir chez
chez vous sénat de façon à avoir toutes
les questions des biens sans maîtres qui
est une question qui est évoqué aussi
dans la loi cadre des donc on est
vraiment sur les phases préliminaires
mais de normes aviez vous lancer
aujourd'hui une plateforme sur internet
pour permettre à des jeunes diplômés
d'accéder à des missions de volontariat
territoriale en administration pour
venir renforcer des collectivités des
collectivités pardon rural qui propose
des postes
quel est l'objectif c'est un ticket
gagnant gagnant pour les collectivités
et les jeunes oui qu'on peut penser qu'à
gagner 11 je crois que bon l'aisne c'est
et le ministère de la cohésion des
territoires propose un certain nombre de
dispositifs d'ingénierie alors il ya des
ingénieries qui sont très adaptés à des
types de collectivités d'autres un peu
moins
bon on a la une c'est mêmes qui se dé
qui se déplace sur les territoires pour
faire des analyses
là d'une école du bois genre je pense à
cela parce que c'est le dernier dossier
que j'ai vu passer le parapheur à un
autre endroit un dossier plus complexe
qui est des dossiers de mise en oeuvre
d'une de patrimoine industriel à gérer a
rénové il ya des journées d'étude qui
sont des journées d'étude sur un marché
national qui sont proposés également aux
collectivités
et puis il ya le génial la collectivité
de base
qui n'est pas dans un programme
forcément un programme national comme
petites villes de deux matchs au coeur
de ville et qui se pose la question de
ses moyens d'ingénierie
cette plateforme est fait pourquoi tout
simplement sur le modèle les volontaires
territoriaux 40 d'entreprise faire en
sorte que des jeunes qui ont un diplôme
de bac + 2 minimum qui ont entre 18 et
30 ans se met en regard de l'offre que
collectivité l'état mettant un ticket
d'entrée de 15000 euros pour toute
embauche de ces jeunes en laissant des
collectivités libres de leur champ
d'action en termes de en termes de
rémunération et ces jeunes auront pour
objet bien tout simplement d'assurer
ingénierie sur ces petits territoires
ont lancé m premier rappel si vous
voulez de 2 200 postes pour voir d'abord
comment ça fonctionne d'ici à la fin du
mois de juillet pour voir s'il faut
réajuster le mécanisme n'a pas toujours
la science infuse mais en tout état de
cause la plateforme qui est la
plateforme vtn c'était point gouv.fr est
aujourd'hui officiellement ouverte
les collectivités mettent leurs offres
les préfets sont deux sont garants
j'allais dire de de la bonne tenue de
cette offre c'est à dire faut pas que ce
soit eu une offre qui correspond à un
emploi de la fonction publique très
classique
ces jeunes arrivent en ingénierie sur
des territoires avec des diplômes
différents
là vous avez peut-être un problème je ne
sais pas superposition l'eau montait le
littoral qui est complexe il vaut mieux
prendre un master en urbanisme faut
essayer de vous des pétards et tout ça
là c'est plutôt de l'ingénierie
classique avec on a des programmes
européens
on allait il le plan de relance on passe
à côté d'elle pas mal de choses parce
qu'on ne sait pas comment instruire ces
dossiers donc notre espoir c'est
effectivement de faire en sorte que l'on
n'ait à la fois des collectivités des
gagnantes d'un côté parce qu'elles
auront de l'ingénierie et des jeunes
qu'ils soient des jeunes gagnants parce
qu'ils n'attendront pas d'avoir une
expérience de cinq ou dix ans pour être
embauchée par teva par les deux petites
villes de demain avec sébastien juste
d'abord je prêt je redis un klein
c'était celle agence nationale de la
cohésion dans ces oui j'avoue fait
actuellement un tour de france pour
promouvoir le dispositif petite ville de
demain à 1624 communes sont concernées
dans un paquet du monde le directeur
général de l'association justement des
petites villes
dis que c'est beaucoup et qu'il ya
peut-être un risque d'émiettement la des
fonds qui sont investis dans ce projet
écoutez je répondais moi je lui réponds
qu il faut quand même savoir le trouvais
qu'il ya beaucoup trop de bourgs centres
en france c'est un peu c'est un peu
paradoxal c'est vrai qu'on est allé 2010
qu'au début il avait listé 700 communes
collègues en à 1625 milliards donc mais
c'est moi oui mais forcément mais
écoutez bon franchement on a quand même
3 milliards sur six ans alors certains
espéraient peut-être concentrer les
moyens sur un nombre limité de
collectivités on a fait le pari avec
jacqueline gourault d'aller très loin
c'est à dire de faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de plancher bas que vous le
savez alors il la plus petite ville de
demain le plus petit petite ville des
deux mais pardonnez moi c'est un village
de 120 habitants tout simplement qui
était chef de canton dans un endroit
très rurale et qui le seul bourg centre
et qui était évidemment en grandes
difficultés compte tenu de sa taille
mettre des moyens sur cette collectivité
a peut être plus de sens que de
renforcer les moyens sur une
collectivité 18000 habitants voilà je
pense qu'il ya des équilibres à trouver
et les moyens seront là de toute façon
ils seront là parce que ce sont pas que
des moyens j'allais dire de stricto
sensu de financier de l'état nous avons
la banque des territoires nous avons
tout un tas de partenaires qui sont des
partenaires à même de proposer ces
emplois lorsque vous arrivez dans des
coeurs de ville où le seul problème
c'est l'habitat dégradé celle agence
nationale d'amélioration de l'habitat
qui va implanter l'ingénierie nécessaire
donc je ne me fais aucun souci pour cela
et vu l'engouement des élus pour ce
programme je vais vous dire que quand
bien même il y aurait un jour besoin
d'ajustements budgétaires je crois que
ce rajustement budget de terre il sera
fait en général dans ces cas là c'est la
demande qui crée l'offre
donc ça veut dire qu'il peut y avoir
plus de première il y avoir des formes
d'ingénierie effectivement nouvelle à
trouver on les trouve regarder les
vétérans sans en font partie donc
nous arrivons à trouver des moyens
d'ingénierie et c'est ça qui est publié
par les collectivités si beaucoup
malheureusement le temps file même s'ils
avaient encore beaucoup de dossiers
abordés avec vous merci jean essentiel
d'avoir et autres invités au regard d
une de l'écho républicain sébastien les
officines sur le front c'est à la une de
votre journal ce matin merci sébastien
port attend d'avoir été avec tous
[Musique]